لكن لماذا كل هذا الخلاف حول مشروع
القانون مشروع القانون المعروف باسم
الوكلاء الاجانب اثارا اضرابات واسعه
وتطورت الاشتباكات عنيفه مع الشرطه في
اعقاب اقرار قراءته الاوليه من البرلمان
رغم قرار سحبه من البرلمان في محاوله طبعا
لتهدئه الراي العام لم يغلق حزب الحلم
الجمهوري او جورج عذرا الحاكم لم يغلق
الباب بالكامل امام عودته مستقبلا هذا
القانون المثير للجدل يهدف الى الكشف عن
تدفقات الاموال القادمه من الخارج حيث
يلزم اي منظمه تتلقى اكثر من 20% من
تمويلها من خارج البلاد بان تسجل نفسها
على انها ضمن الوكلاء الاجانب والا ستواجه
غرامات قد تصل الى حوالي عشره الاف دولار
امريكي طبعا تعتبر وزاره العدل التشريعي
يستهدف كشف تاثير العملاء الاجانب في
البلاد يرى مؤيد ان الولايات المتحده
لديها قانون مشابه وهو قانون تسجيل
العملاء الاجانب المقابل يرى معارضون
تشريعا انه تقليد لروسيا وما تنتهجه من
تضييق على حريه التعبير والاعلام كما
يعتبرونه اشاره الى ان النفوذ الروسي في
جورجيا بدا يتزايد الاهم من ذلك من وجهه
نظر معارضيها انه يقلل من فرص انضمام
جورجيا للاتحاد الاوروبي ففي السنوات
الماضيه واجهت ابليس انتقادات متزايده
بشان ما يعتقد انه تراجع عن الديمقراطيه
ما اساء للعلاقات مع بروكسل واشنطن دخلت
على خط الازمه حيث عبرت عن قلقها ازاء
القانون دعت السلطات الاحترام المظاهرات
السلميه وحريه التعبير والاحتجاج